[Music]
so how does it feel to be in this movie
and an awesome female superhero
it feels pretty darn cool this is um
this is a highlight of my career for
sure and I would say that yeah yeah I
would I would and you know not just
because not just because I get to be a
superhero but because I get to be the
first titled female superhero in the MCU
and that's a big deal to me and huge
deal it feels it feels really important
especially in this climate in this
moment with our culture and with women
so clearly saying we're still not being
treated equally and times up we've got
to be treated equally to now have equal
billing with a man in this universe
that's predominantly male is um means a
lot to me yeah and you definitely whole
held your own hold your own thank you
yeah there's no doubt about that was it
you said you have dreamt all of your
life you know as a kid you've always
thought it would be cool to have wings
because you liked fairies and yeah
Pixies
I loved fairies and Pixies but now I get
to kind of be like a kick-ass but you
dreamed up right yeah irony somebody who
works for Marvel and they always ask
their kid to come and they have a
daughter and she's always like no it's
not my thing is that my thing is that my
thing and this one they said well um you
know it's it's a woman she was like
uh-huh and he's like she has wings and
she was like what like for me just
bringing girls into this space and
giving them something really cool I
don't know I'm just very happy very
excited did you call up Scarlett
Johansson have you guys compared notes
about being these you know kicked butt
females you know whenever you are King
uh when I was working on Avengers I got
to know brie Larson pretty well and or
you know a little bit as much as you can
on a film and and her and I talked about
it and of course she's gonna be the next
titled female superheroes she's gonna be
Captain Marvel and then I'm sure that
you know this will be the beginning of
many many more titled Marvel films yeah
Widow Scarlet Witch I mean I don't know
who's next or who's gonna get it but
like it's not it's just the beginning
yeah
it's true did you compare the very
beginning of it with scarlet II know
it's about baby
I never I've never had a chance to talk
to Scarlett yeah I need to get I know
it'd be great yeah you're paving the way
for us tough email are you getting some
cool mom points for being the wasp um
yeah I mean especially nuts my son is
seven and he's at that place of like
mom's not cool so he doesn't like the
fact that I've got this cool card cuz
then he admittedly does think it's cool
but he tries not to admit it but his
friends you know at school it's
definitely a kind of a big thing you
know I go to school and think it's cool
but they kind of look at you like sign I
like kind of like some of them someone
that are really brazen like one of them
I went there for career day and I talked
to the kids about my writing career
probably predominantly like I mostly
just read them my stories but I gave
them a QA time so that they could ask
any questions they wanted and one of
them put his hand up and said how much
money do you have
I full-on went into mommy mode I was
like that's a rude question I should
never ask anybody about money as private
that is hilarious yeah oh my gosh I
understand you did catch her son though
pretending to be the wasp
yeah he came to visit me on set and we
we were on the beautiful Hank and hope
lab set which is just completely
immersive and there's buttons and
gadgets and he was playing with
everything and he was on in his own
world and his imagination and all of a
sudden he turned to me and his father
and said um look at me I'm the wasps and
I mean that just as a mom for your son
to be pretending to be you is really
cool but then as a woman to see a little
boy pretending to be a female superhero
meant the world to me I mean I remember
distinctly pretending to be male
superheroes when I was young and and and
that shift is incredible my son has
always though kind of had this mom that
like like I I don't remember why but at
one point we asked my partner and I
asked him if I'm like a robbery came
into the house
who do you think would like save you or
like protect you would it be mommy or
daddy and he was like mommy like seeing
me slaying orcs
yeah and he's just always seen me like
he really believes I can sleep he really
believes
I know muy Thai you really believe I try
to tell him like no honey it's all
pretend but he's seen the footage yeah
you know he's seen it to happen has he
seen this film not yet yeah well he's
really gonna thank you gentlemen the
trailer and he's already just like oh my
mom connects me kick some ass I
understand the Stute was not so
comfortable at some point I loved my
suit you said you know why you think my
suit was so uncomfortable is because all
the men and the Marvel world complain
about their time ah they're wimps you
know well I'm used to being
uncomfortable to look good we walk
around in high heels and Nick stop I
mean we're just like that's why did I
put my pale unfair but you know women
are I think generally used to being
uncut so we don't notice it as mash but
they're not used to being uncomfortable
so but you were very instrumental in
shaping yeah the wasp suit right yeah I
wasn't right from the beginning
no but none of them are I mean you you
can't get a suit to be form-fitting and
yeah hug a person's body without having
had them in a room for hours on end and
making it perfect but we I mean I really
think I spent like a ridiculous so by
making sure that that suit was right I
would call up the wardrobe department
and say I know production scheduled us
for two hours yeah but we need all day
right and they're like oh we love all
day and I'm like I'm here for you if we
need five days you just tell me we're
gonna get this suit perfect what were
some of the problems like with it once
they became like flat yeah one of the
worst things was it gave me a really
flat butt and I don't have a flat butt
and I was like guys we gotta represent
if I had a flat butt fine but I don't so
you need to make me look my best since I
mean it's in sort of almost embarrassing
to talk about what you know but like you
need to get the breast shape perfect
because it shouldn't be I didn't want it
to be garish I didn't want it to be like
the comic books it was really focused on
TNA it was very focused on the curves
and being buxom I'm there all Barbies in
the coming no hello like I just not I I
have small breasts and narrow hips and
like I'm more athletic so I wanted it to
be sexy and beautiful but I wanted it to
be realistic and modern as well and like
that battery beautifying yeah that is
tricky but good for you for doing that
thank you
can we just talk about the huge legends
in this movie well Michael decklist
Michelle Pfeiffer Laurence Fishburne did
you ever look around Paul said I just
became like kind of starstruck sometimes
and I know people could say that but he
literally it was like literally I would
think like in between scenes what
questions can I ask them because I have
like things I want to ask I can confirm
that he's not pretending you would look
like between a take you can see him like
a kid like then he come up with like
Lawrence and you would like dig for
great Hollywood stories you know any
warrants has epic stories michael has
epic stories like those men lived hard
and fast in the 80s you know and they've
got amazing stories to tell and Michelle
is so cool and so funny and so so
generous and kind like I didn't ask any
of them for any questions because I was
too afraid of prying huh I was like oh
like they're so it was truly a dream to
work with them and I felt like a
spectator like I just was always just
watching them like I did get I did dig
in with Lawrence a little bit on his
life and he's just such a connected
person he's really approachable and warm
and he makes even really puts people at
ease yeah and so I felt like I could
talk to him about his life story and
he's got such a fascinating life yeah
they all derelict just incredible stuff
the duo because you and Paul have such
great chemistry in this movie and the
duo between the ant-man and the wasp do
you think it's gonna go down as one of
the great duo's of all time or like a
Batman and Robin I I have no idea mean
really like you know if something's
given like when I we started filming
loss we didn't know it would
come the thing it became you know you
that I don't have a crystal ball but I I
personally think it's the best part of
the movie I love I love the chemistry I
love the friction
it's very moonlight EE like you know
those show new lighting where they
parties they love each other because
they hate each other and because they're
so different so there's a really getting
yang factor to Scott and hope and you
know the first film she thought he was
unnecessary useless and obnoxious and
then eventually you know he he found a
way into her heart and he thought she
was cold aloof and a [ __ ] you know and
then she found a way into his heart but
at the beginning of this film
they've already dated yeah they've had a
romance they've been through that
journey and now they're estranged yeah
so they have history and they have some
baggage to get through and it's really
fun seeing them watching them work
through that baggage I know he didn't
really have yeah like a romantic comedy
yeah I now lost would you ever do
reboots did you brought that up
ah it's all the rage these days I hate
reboots
you J hey I'm just like can you please
leave Star Wars alone rogue one was
amazing but other than that I just like
leave it alone it's like legendary and
perfect I don't want an Indiana Jones
reboot I don't want like all these
things are so precious and sacred and
like I just feel like reboots end up
somehow watering down what erage was so
beautiful in the first place so if they
wanted to do a lost reboot I just feel
like I would be risking hurting the
original thing that we did and I feel
like we did it well and it was beautiful
and we should just let it be I'll take
that as a no I never say never I mean I
just like life is too complicated so
yeah yeah that's true but I hear what
you're saying yeah you were so great in
the movie thanks for being a little off
in the movie with you I got that I mean
thank you so much